welcome back to New rockstars this is
the breakdown of the Clone Tyrone on
Netflix I love they clone Tyrone I
couldn't and wouldn't shut up about it
boss actually went to school with the
writer director Joelle Taylor and we
took this opportunity to tackle this
incredible film together which includes
a special interview with dwell himself
in this video I'll be exploring
reviewing and explaining some of the
most profound artistic social commentary
delivered in a movie since get out and
to reiterate sag-aftra has informed us
that entertainment journalists like new
rockstars are allowed to cover movies
and TV shows during the strike clearly
obviously we stand with the writers and
the actors on strike to get working
conditions that they all deserve and
this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the all-in-one platform that makes
launching your own website a breeze this
movie is Incredible movies like nope
sorry to bother you and they clone
Tyrone are like the black
espionage-esque sci-fi Thrillers I've
been begging for Joelle Taylor calling
it a bootleg Scooby-Doo is beyond
accurate and you don't have to think too
hard to understand the social commentary
in play historically black folks have
been oppressed scrutinized enslaved in
America trembled by our government
killed by those who are sort of protect
and clearly systemically instructed
actually bound to prejudicial laws or
beliefs leading to unfair treatment or
disadvantages like segregation
gentrification voter suppression all the
above they clone Tyrone takes these very
serious ideas to Heart using satire to
remind us and question how This Racist
system operates so effortlessly and in
this movie spoilers The call is coming
from inside the house baby Joelle
mentions in a different interview with
Higher Learning that you can interpret
this ending A Million Ways a guy having
a conversation with himself or the black
community taking a look at itself you
can take it however you want so maybe
the call isn't coming from within the
house but just in this movie it
absolutely is the movie doesn't focus on
the man named Tyrone actually but three
people in the middle of it all John
boyega's Fontaine a drug dealer yo-yo a
sex worker played by Tiana Paris my girl
and her pimps like played by Jamie Foxx
who I was confident improvised a lot of
his lines which Tiana Paris mentions
they did improvise a ton of lines in
this movie slick felt like a comedic
relief but in all honesty their
authentic reactions to paranoia and fear
is the true comedy like no if you'll
never catch me getting into the sneaky
[__] unless you know like my home's
involved which is why they're doing half
the [__] they're doing in their first
place in this movie it takes place in
the neighborhood The Glenn but it was
actually filmed in Atlanta at black Hall
Studios Joelle mentioned they live in a
place that's been forgotten a place that
extends beyond space and time he said
you couldn't pinpoint the accent like it
wasn't too Southern so if people were
like people from Atlanta don't sound
like that well that's because they ain't
from Atlanta where is the Glen for you
like where is your Glen I mean Glenn is
home and like you know like I'm I'm from
Tuskegee I grew up in Montgomery so a
lot of uh you know just a lot of the
location a lot of the personality you
know comes from just being back home you
know business
quality of
being lost in time that we you know kind
of
pursue with the production design and
the tone
and you know a lot of things when I
think about like Tuskegee
you know you got the shopping center
that was you know it used to have a
Walmart and a dominoes and then like
time I was a kid and Walmart ever been
replaced with like a Hobby Lobby and The
Dominoes and all the pop and then that
got replaced but then even more bootleg
version of The Hobby Lobby you know and
so there's this like patina of like
the 80s even though you know
you're in the 90s now even then all of a
sudden you're in the 2000s you're in the
Arts you're in the 2010s and you still
have this 80s patina on a lot of things
and so
yeah I think it gives it a lot of charm
though at the beginning of the movie
Fontaine enters a convenience store
called got drinks God damn we see the
classic Colt 45 but he grabs the
Anaconda malt liquor from the 2009 film
Black Dynamite
we even see an ad board outside the
store peep all those missing person
Flyers this is Aaliyah Jackson who also
is a stunt actor we see her a couple
times throughout the movie she's getting
CDs at the very beginning of the film
she's imprisoned underground and
Clockwork Orange then at the end she's
free hugging her family we're introduced
to Frog who I knew looked familiar
that's Leon Lamar who played Cornelius P
Willows and She-Hulk and owned the
Mystic Castle when we meet frog he says
it's in the water Young Blood later he
says off to see the wizard again towards
the end of the movie he starts saying
stuff like you always lose and you got
that new cost Mill young blood after the
newest clone of him was made it's safe
to assume this crazy old man was
probably kidnapped experimented on and
became defective these are test trials
with most products and Kiefer Sutherland
even says this Benjamin was one of our
existing products just a little more
potent now but
a little touch and go still so you might
experience some side effects so try not
to lose your mind okay so you can lose
your mind from experiments which
probably happened to frog and now he
just lives spewy nonsense that's not
actually nonsense he's the least
hazardous thing at the Glen so they
probably thought there's no use in
getting rid of him I read in your
interview with Hollywood Reporter how
like the original idea you know we don't
meet Tyrone until the end of the movie
but one idea was to make the character a
frog the uh Tyrone and then you were
just gonna hide it in his costuming his
makeup and everything like that can you
talk us through your decision in the
evolution of who is going to be Tyrone
in this movie
yeah I mean when we are going back to
when we were developing into picture you
know so we pitched like pretty detail
outline you know um so we we pitched it
was a super long kids we pitched um
basically everything in the movie now
obviously that was as it was in 2018 so
it's not everything in this version of
the movie but
while we were you know kind of
developing it we knew from the beginning
that Fontaine wasn't going to be Tyrone
we knew
whoever Tyrone is he won't be the main
character
and that was just because we thought it
was funny in the beginning
we'll be contrarians and and make it
make it somebody else
and that the natural next question is
who
um and so
you know
organically you can't we kind of came to
two people that it could be you know the
first being like frog in terms of you
know
explaining you know why does why is this
wino at the liquor store like why is he
degree out of this neighborhood so to
speak you know uh it's like oh well
obviously the an easy way to metabolize
that is if he is you and he's seen
everything that you're doing and he's
been you know watching every Innovation
with him since you know since himself
and so it it that one was a you know
that one was one that we thought
I mean we had this scene where like he
was going to take him out to a diner and
they were you know like a restaurant
um you know treat him to lunch and buy
him a meal and like get some of the
spill
and then you know it wasn't that big of
a leap from there
uh saying again like if you're going
back to like the root of it like who
would who would the most logical person
to beat Tyrone it's clearly OG right
like they call him Tyrone oh gee is
Tyrone they cloned him they made many
more Fontaine is talking to his mother
between the bedroom door later and we
find out that his mother is a tape
recorder playing audio of what I assume
is the real fontaine's mother I assume
every time the Clone version of him is
killed a new clone comes up with the
same [__] you know different clone day
additionally I know damn well this
wouldn't be me when I live with my mom I
bothered her every single second of the
day regardless the scene was
heartbreaking and I hated it we got a
commercial for goddamn chicken sort of
like Anaconda Malt Liquor the Black
Dynamite being created by the US
government to Target black men got damn
chicken contain compound H used to mind
control black people I'm sorry but these
like fake commercials and black movies
always get me like pork chops a chunky
and how high or Soul Gloom Coming to
America outside the store we see a sign
for Summer according to Netflix's
interview with Joelle Taylor this is an
Easter egg reference to Aldous huxley's
Brave New World it's a derivative of so
the mood altering drug given to citizens
to keep them peaceful and happy exactly
like compound H in the chicken it's a
pleasure inducing powder regardless
there's a ton of references and
stereotypical points made in this film
all brainwashing comes back to the
church chicken perms in an interview
with Van Lathan and Rachel Lindsay of
Higher Learning Joelle mentions it's all
a matter of perception and never to
demonize what's depicted he mentioned
it's common not wanted to eat chicken or
watermelon in front of white people so
why is that using satire he stretches it
and tries to have fun in the discomfort
having a website is like having a
business card if you run a business you
kind of need one and that means you need
Squarespace Squarespace is an all-in-one
platform that provides you with
everything you need to do whatever you
need with your website Squarespace says
templates and designs for every category
and use case so even if you're making
your very first website using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update your content
and add features to fit your unique
needs if you're selling merch
Squarespace makes it easy to do that too
you can design your products then save
time and money by letting Squarespace
handle production inventory and shipping
and if you're selling any other kind of
physical Goods digital Goods or even a
service Squarespace makes it easy to
build your storefront and grow your
business to check out for yourself head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain yo yo who we see later is my
favorite character not only does this
movie have our very own Monica Rambo
making Spider-Man references but she's
also up to date on everything in pop
culture and this one scene she mentions
this weird-ass guy either being a cop or
on some Hannibal [__] yes the cannibal
animal Silence of the Lambs type she
calls Jamie Foxx a habitual line stepper
now I know the reference coined by
Charlie Murphy on Chappelle Show when
talking about Rick James and I think
that's what she's referring to she even
references Jedi Mind Tricks and she's
learning to invest in blockchain the
cryptocurrency also she's a Nancy Drew
Aficionado the Nancy Drew book she uses
as a reference later is the hidden
staircase this is where Nancy Drew finds
a secret staircase leading to a large
tunnel where she finds her father in
prison kinda like this movie yo-yo is
our bootleg Velma and what's not to love
about about this character she's the
heart and soul of the entire operation
becoming successful music plays a huge
role in this movie and the Easter eggs
lie so deep it's hard to notice until
dwell brings it up in other interviews
during this scene Slick's listening to
shirelle's Saturday love the chorus
repeats Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday like this
happens over and over again because this
feels like an endless loot later at the
church as David Alan Greer preaches
nonsense they're playing an instrumental
of Back That Ass Up the Erica Badu
re-recorded and remixed a version of
Tyrone to somebody clone Tyrone and it
has a mind control reference when Los
Angeles Fontaine is driving in his car
the music alludes to mind control saying
you are enslaved to do what I say Don't
Stop Till You Get Enough playing once
they enter the lab the first time I mean
like come on the motto of the entire
operation is basically don't stop until
everyone assimilates it's all there it's
proof in the pudding proof in the
pudding I don't know maybe that's the
same we'll keep going it seems like the
opening exchange of the movies about
Michael Jackson that's kind of
conspiracy theory that's like oh no he's
black again and then I noticed later
when we see the lab tech he's dancing
and Don't Stop Till You Get Enough was
that an intentional nod to Michael
Jackson like what the OG Fontaine well
yeah I mean I think we were just having
fun with foreshadowing kind of some of
the more uh
weird things about the plot as you go in
the kind of walking master plan is
basically like
you know just what happened to Michael
Jackson you know on the math scale right
and so
you're just having fun foreshadowing
though some of the turns that would come
later so you know Michael Jackson was a
black man he became a white man and so
why not why not started with that
because that's ultimately
that's ultimately where it's going
Joelle mentions an interview with
Netflix how the audio Engineers looked
into sub-oral frequency which is below
the threshold of hearing to sneak in
Morse code and the music that changes
them the morse code basically says stop
and surround them stop and subdue them
and then when they're free from the
music at the strip club the beat
basically says Carry On music plays a
huge pivotal point in Black Culture
always has and always will following a
sort of like you know conspiracy theory
you know how they say like it's in the
water like in this movie it's like it's
in the music I mean which is not far off
from like Tick Tock Trends and dances
that [__] got us in a Chokehold right
slick mentions being 1995's
International Players Ball pimp of the
Year and no it's not just a bit from
Chappelle's Show where I'm Gonna Get You
suck up inspiration from the mac and an
actual event that I'm pretty sure is
actively still going I I'm pretty sure
it is it's an annual thing Fontaine then
gets shot and the scene is horrible but
damn that lighting is on point the set
deck the cinematographers the lighting
technicians really popped off Fontaine
does the same [__] different clone day
before getting into his car he notices a
man walking down the street with a gray
hoodie bloodlining it I assume this was
Fontaine the night before stumbling from
God knows where at first he's curious
takes a sip of his drink and continues
to stare then we get this look and I
feel like he starts noticing damn that
man looks like me then based on this
look it's confirmed when he hears the
scream that that's probably him and like
that it's done a problem for sure but
it's unfortunately something that
happens a lot you don't want to snitch
you don't want to go to the police it's
like mind your own business mentality
it's a shitty situation they even Kiefer
Sutherland's character comment saying
you do nothing you go back to your
regular lives do what you do best look
the other way it's a shitty shitty
situation that happens too often in life
and it cuts immediately to his brother's
obituary who had the same situation
happen to him he was shot in the street
and bled out slowly because no one
helped he was alive for 15 minutes and
it's horrible then we have slick
fighting yo-yo again so like loves
coming for yoyo's Wig this isn't really
a missed detail more so a wig always
saves the day when later we see yo-yo
get the Mind Control perm but to her wig
because they don't know it wasn't real
and I I just love this scene I love it
you keep coming for the wig but the wig
saves the day when they break into the
trap house with a secret lab on the TV
it's playing blood Sports specifically
the scene where they blow that white
powder in Van Damme's face in the middle
of the fight and contrast is something
we learned in this movie and we should
be completely fearful of the compound H
the white substance powder which also
leaves you disoriented like Van Damme
Fontaine finds the elevator to the
secret lab in an interview with Netflix
they spoke about this scene of the
elevator how Jamie Foxx and Tiana Paris
did different versions of that song that
was written in the script but every take
was completely different and they
encouraged so much improv and I just
think it's so sweet to see that
Additionally the elevators aren't real
they use green screens and lights that
mirrored the effective doors opening and
for the church elevator they used a
static elevator on a Sound Stage then we
enter the lap to this white man dancing
hard as hell with an afro it's unnerving
we later find out from old Fontaine this
is the last leg of the experiments but
the hair is just too stubborn to get
right so allegedly these were ones black
people that have been brainwashed and
conditioned these labs are giving like
you know Cabin in the Woods I assumed it
gave them inspiration but when
protection built these labs they asked
themselves what if MK Ultra never shut
down and evolved what would it look like
MK Ultra is the CIA program from the 50s
ending in the 70s that studied mind
control experiments centered around
electroshock therapy hypnosis polygraphs
radiation and a variety of drugs like
LSD this was done on humans and a lot of
prisoners some who consented or
volunteered but arguably a lot didn't a
lot were persuaded with lesser prison
sentences or just didn't know what they
were signing up for or doing until the
drugs took effect Whitey Boulder or
Bulger the the mobster from Boston
detailed a story about how they made him
and his inmates do LSD and then they all
freaked out if this sounds familiar you
probably read or heard of the story of
project artichoke which was succeeded by
MK Ultra doing the same stuff we wrote a
hope dossier
um
that goes through the history of
the history of MK Ultra and how it
shuttered in the 70s and became MK Opera
and like you know so you know they went
from making trying to make battleships
disappear and uh wormwood and you know
midnight yeah let's see trying to like
use LSD and they suddenly got more
sophisticated like you know we wrote
this whole like you know uh bassiere and
we typed it in like a courier and we
were deck and it was like you know it
was part of my pitch to actors actually
it took this we binded this folder and
made a stamp and the whole thing and we
brought it to Jamie and like gave it to
him
you know um but in that was a lot of the
you know a lot of the world doing that
we started building out of as a this
joke of just saying like let's make
Tyrone somewhere random all right well
let's do random maybe he's not in the
Glen he's not in the Glenn where is he
okay he could be anywhere maybe they're
everywhere like maybe you know what I
mean we get a glimpse of young yo-yo's
room and just to remind y'all it's
definitely not the 70s or 80s because
she has a picture of Obama but also a
picture of Mae Jemison our first black
female astronaut it's been talked about
time and time again and I love this
interview on Shadow and act between
Tiana and John boyega where they talk
about this chicken scene how the chicken
was cold and hard as a rock but John
Boyer got fresh hot chicken brought to
him after hearing that you can see the
difference in yoyo and Slick eating
their chicken and Fontaine really eating
his chicken normally I'd love a church
rub by David Alan Greer but clearly we
recognize this is all a front they're
serving grape drank and preaching that
nothing matters no problem is too big as
long as you trust in his vision and I
know they ain't talking about that why
Jesus behind them so they're talking
about older Fontaine once they're in the
lab under the church we learned the
church leads to the central Concourse
goddamn chicken is one of the offices
and other places like the check cash and
place the motel and the strip club
double as testing Suites shipping docks
and the research and development like
Nancy Drew in the Hidden Staircase these
tunnels lead to different Secrets A lab
technician has a phone line tap talking
about Keisha and Daquan writing his
notes all about it Jewel mentions this
romantic Saga is seen throughout the
movie after being shot when Fontaine
wakes up we hear a couple arguing
and that's actually Keisha and Daquan
later Daquan tells Keisha they're going
to be late to the cookout
and throughout the songs you hear Keisha
mentioned every now and then
we're listening to Diana Ross's love
hangover right when we see this poster
right here it says Unity starts here
with a white man and a lab coat holding
a double helix we see this poster right
as the song says if there's a cure for
this I don't want it again furthering
the message and alluding to the
brainwashing and assimilation in the
music I love this movie then we start
seeing all the lab testing this man
getting electroshock therapy is actually
Joelle Taylor's brother and this girl I
mentioned earlier on the missing flyers
and whatnot she's actually watching
videos of black women getting their hair
permed Joelle mentioned in an interview
with Netflix how she was being
conditioned through psychological
suggestions of what beauty standards are
their study in the connotation of
violence directly connected to rap music
in this scene this weird notion that
only rap music contributes to violent
tendencies once the music changes to
lighter softer tones they quit fighting
and begin to hug again like a lot of
themes in this movie dwell as taking
satirical approach to Serious themes
they leave the lab through a secret door
leading to the strip club the names on
the lockers are unique and Dominique I
love it later when we see the DJ's
playlist on the top of the list is
Raheem the Dream this is a call out to
Raheem the Dream and his song head he
calls out the twin freaks unique and
Dominique I think it's super interesting
when talking about the sets and shooting
Joelle mentioned the strip club scene
was the hardest scene to shoot it was
supposed to be a normal club with a ton
of people but because of covid they had
to switch it up what went from wanting
200 background actors to getting only 65
so they had to switch up the background
actors close and shoot them out in
different Corners to make it look full
and busy all in one day then we get key
for Sutherland and what the hell is this
this cast seat is so good yo-yo calls
him Kevin Bacon and has made references
to Kevin Bacon specifically in a hollow
man throughout this movie Hollow Man is
where Kevin Bacon plays an invisible
rapist he's a scientist that develops a
serum to make himself invisible and of
course he does horrific stuff in the
movie and in the name of science just
like monster Hollow Man Kevin Bacon
Kiefer Sutherland is doing it in the
name of science so basically keeper
tells them the only way to keep the
United States United it starts with
studying the Glen basically changing who
they are to assimilate he mentions if
they took everyone all at once
gentrification would step in disallowing
them to further their studies everyone
has a part to play so they've used
people like Fontaine and Slick to keep
the place from being gentrified so they
can continue to study the good folks as
we've seen in history the neighborhoods
with higher poverty or crime rate are
rarely visited by any government
officials and just harassed by the
police so no one will really think twice
or see something's up it's perfectly
outside the world's radar but we hold on
that not all hope is lost in this movie
when bitty sees yo-yo later delivering a
letter to the Washington Post in
Disguise she calls her Carmen sandyho I
just love that I love the Dave I love
Carmen San Diego so this was a great
call out for me
the greatest plan of all time we get him
sitting on the back of a low rider with
the calvary 's wardrobe is actually
based on Ron O'Neill from Superfly this
scene of them destroying the lab was the
Holy Grail of shots they only had one
take to do it they played Knuck If You
Buck Right before tearing it all up
Joelle was telling the scientists don't
let him catch you just to get the stakes
up behind the scenes then we finally
reveal that the ultimate big bad was the
old Fontaine so old Fontaine is the lead
geneticist of the operation and he's
doing all of this because of his little
brother Ronnie who died he deduces the
problem is in the people the unnecessary
violence and the non-supportive nature
it's revealed that somehow old Fontaine
was able to find the genes that separate
black hoods from other neighborhoods and
if he fixed those genes he could make it
better while America is playing the
small game wasting resources on Fried
Chicken perms whatever he's working on
true assimilation where we must
literally be the same he says to himself
assimilation is better than annihilation
ew no I hate that arfontaine is able to
survive knowing the code word Olympia
Black I'm from Olympia and I'm black and
using the Clone protecting old Fontaine
to fire on him killing him instantly so
I assume the Clones can use Olympia
Black if they want but they choose not
to because they're mostly already
assimilated by this point there's no
reason for slick to use it randomly but
at this moment it helped Fontaine so I
think if there's a second movie this is
something that could come up for those
that we know the code Olympia Black to
use it to reprimand the other clones in
the area the phrase Olympia Black is
something that a lot of people are kind
of speculating about is it a reference
to the Sci-Fi author is it reference to
Olympia Washington what was your idea
behind that that's funny so a couple
people have asked this and I always feel
like I'm like damn so this ironically
enough was like the one thing that gets
asked about like this gets asked about
more than the Soma and it's the one
thing where it was a complete
serendipitous coincidence playing that
so we didn't know about
like my human pen until we were asked a
question about it he was like what like
because we we
tried to find but you know trying to
find you know phrases that had like
double meanings we didn't like the Ring
of it like it turned it just the way
is the phonetics in general and he's
like
I won't be a black they got a nice ring
to it you know what I'm saying so we we
ultimately came back to Olympia Black
and ironically enough of all the things
that people like look for in terms of
the Easter eggs that's the word that I
feel like the most people
look searched for and ultimately ended
up finding an Easter egg again where I
said that's the one that I wish we were
smart enough to
flame credit for that and say like oh
yeah we definitely meant to do that but
that was actually a complete happy
accident
um which sounds unbelievable but trust
me I I would I would claim it I would
like to it it would only make us look
like we're actually smart the Clones
ended for the most part or at least that
we know of biddy's last words are my
favorite and personally stole the show
for me yeah that's right we had deep
dope that [__]
Water Gave calmed down I got the
receipts right here they cloning
[__] as we speak in secret
Laboratories in Chicago Illinois uh
Detroit Michigan Los Angeles California
we think all's well and the hoods come
together then we introduced a slightly
different Fontaine in Los Angeles doing
the same [__] Fontaine did waking up
talking to their mom working out in the
car listening to mind control music he
leaves his Mark passing the Anaconda
Malt Liquor posters cores La frog some
40. they're even seen later eating
Crunch cereal that we saw at the lab
it's also open-ended we could easily get
a part two the reveal of Tyrone seeing
his clone self was perfect in the last
words of the film come from dwell
Taylor's perfect Cameo appearance ain't
that true Tyrone could you do a Tyrone
Cinematic Universe at this point because
we have the LA chapter which is his own
story
The Tyrone Cinema universities is uh
every movie would be a different a
totally different style of Movie that
that does not it's the movie that came
before that's what it would be uh so the
next one they opened they open a pizza
shop they open the bakery and it's just
the three of them in a workplace comedy
we don't we only refer to in the first
two minutes like you know it's crazy
what happened last week yeah I know
right and then you'd never talk about
the fact that people got my clones you
never talk about anything that happened
anything is good they just they've got
to get these pizzas you know got to get
these pizzas ready because the
businesses is uh is failing and they've
got to figure out a new recipe for beef
pizzas that's it for our breakdown on
they clone Tyrone I love this movie so
much and I love Joelle Taylor I will be
consuming anything and everything this
man makes going forward I came back
generosity to do this because I I love
this movie so much I wanted to talk
about it I love you should love
supporting black writers actors and
directors I beg them to let me do this
they were like Jessica you can do this
if you want I was like thank you go
watch it go watch it a million times
like me and my mom did subscribe to new
rockstars the break room and the Deep
dive for more analysis of everything you
love and support them by grabbing some
merch at nerdriot.shop follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu underscore
Clemons thanks for watching see you
later
thank you